i'm scouring the country in a quest to
find my very best restaurant
my coach load of 30 diners is about to
hit the second chinese restaurant
battling for a place in the semi-finals
of my nationwide competition it's family
run you and you in blackburn so many of
you nominated them you and you had to go
into my top two chinese
it's got that that energy that vibe and
this family run run with great passion
you can feel that because they care
about every little detail
family is the most important part of
this restaurant i think personally it
makes this restaurant what it is you
know it that's the heart and soul of the
restaurant it's not just a livelihood
it's more than that it's a definite
passion
dad charlie started out with a chippy
over 30 years ago before opening his
first restaurant in 1989. he's 65.
there's still flames in him you know
he's like he's quicker than me
there's a saying um the older the ginger
the hotter it gets now all three of his
children work in the business
what makes this restaurant stand out is
that charli and his head chef son victor
source the very best local ingredients
the scallops are massive arrived um this
morning they're beautiful thank you
you and you will have just two hours to
serve all 30 of my diners a perfect meal
i'm excited i'm ready tonight's dishes
include hand-dived salt and pepper
scallops fill it steak with hoisin and
chili bean sauce and a luxurious
stir-fry dover soul
absolutely delicious it's cooked briefly
and for me what that dish needs is just
a touch more seasoning yeah thank you
just thank you
side order with your main course
my diners look excited by what's on
offer but i wish the front of house team
would make a point of telling them how
fantastic the raw ingredients are like
salt pepper scallops with asparagus and
mushrooms
for all they know the scallops could
have come from the supermarket
it's victor and charlie's chance to show
me they can handle this challenge
let the food do the talking
once that turbo wok is fired up does she
start flying out the door
amazing
yeah wow that's quick
it's just over two minutes from the
first order coming in for food to leave
the kitchen
victor's brother and sister are joined
front of house by at least eight other
waiting staff who seem to do a lot of
waiting seems to be a lot of people just
milling about and not really paying the
attention to the table
are we having a beauty pageant in here
look at these waitresses in here
blackburn's next top model
it's complete overkill and half the time
they don't even know where to put
themselves
my main concern is the way the kitchen
is working
victor the head chef picks the
ingredients
another chef adds the
sauce then it's dad charlie who does all
the cooking
65 years of age he's there pounding
every dish just cooking cooking cooking
i'm not even coming up rare
alex no man's the only one doing all the
work
don't you feel guilty
that's the way you wanted to do it
that's how he wants to do it
charlie huh want some help yeah yeah
yeah yeah
in the kitchen that's a little bit weird
for me the only one doing any work is
your dad he's control control is he a
control fruit
yeah is he yeah
needs to let go a little bit
he still thinks he's going to do one day
a week at 90 seriously seriously yeah